In the course, we're going to build
a weather app called Sunshine.
The main screen is a list
of this week's forecast,
with an emphasized presentation
for today's weather.
With just a quick glance, I can decide if,
today is a stay inside and code day.
Or if I should code from the park instead.
We have icons
to indicate conditions, like snow,
rain, fog or sunshine.
We can scroll through the list,
to see a long range forecast.
With a click on one of the forecasts,
we bring up a detailed view containing
the rest of the weathery goodness,
which also gives us the ability
to share the weather with our friends.
We can go to Settings
and change the unit of measure,
as well as the location.
The app can even post
system wide notifications,
to let us know about weather conditions
without even entering the app.
So, you might ask,
why are we building a weather app?
We chose the weather app
because it's a simple concept,
which touches most of the core APIs
we want to teach and everyone
can relate to weather,
unless you're in a bunker.
By the end of the course,
you'll be able to use those APIs
and concepts to build your own app
for your final project.